I hope that we'll have the time to see
the two games that I prepared we'll
definitely see the first one but I'll go
relatively fast so we'll have time for
the other the first one is from the 1927
World Championship and it's a game
between hazard capablanca and alexandra
yahan I'm not going to say Alec I'm
sorry but you know who it is and it's
always impressive to see one of the
former world champions lose in a way
that he loses in this game especially
someone like capablanca I was extremely
talented and the funny thing is that I
get this game somewhere else and then I
looked through it on chess base and the
commentate the comments on chess base
actually borrow a lot of the ideas that
were analyzed after the game both by
alaqah and yochim and commons by other
masters of the past now with the benefit
of having great chess computers like
starfish 7 for example you see how their
comments and insights are so often it's
really amazing it's like della touch a
question mark to remove and the computer
says best choice or they'll say this is
a great move at the computer cells now
maybe third choice and this is after you
let it churn for a while just really
impressive how strong they have become
so our first game is again as promised
kappa blanka on your home so d4 d5 again
a classical treatment of the d4 opening
c4 e6 Knight c3 Knight f6 Bishop g5 9 b7
ok not the most flexible move but
definitely one of the main Lions III I
really hope I don't have to discuss at
greater length because this is kind of
painful for me what happened if you
tried to win the pawn on d5 some of you
might know the trap are already smiling
I can tell you that I was in the World
Championship and one of my students the
World Championship fell into this trap I
don't know he was who was more sad she
or I but there were tears the point of
course just without moving the pieces
for those who don't know pawn takes pawn
takes Knight takes looks like a great
move because it wins upon right the
knight is
well that's the difference between an
absolute pin and a relative pin because
here you can just take the night and
after Bishop da Bishop to b4 check the
queen is coming back with interest so
you can see that after Queen here takes
take and I take the bishop white ended
up just being a piece down you just lose
a piece from this I'm not very advisable
well of course someone like kappa blanka
is not not interested in that kind of
junk
so Bishop e7 okay not after another
going to discuss the opening a great
length because again 1927 so many things
were different
castles looked to see one again there's
a tiny bit of a battle here about the
captures on d4 on c4 white is reluctant
to move his Bishop to e2 or d3 because
of pawn takes pawn on c4 the bishop will
have to move again and recapture and
then potentially Knight d5 you know it's
a moment
so he is trying to play useful moves
without committing his Bishop if black
will take now on c4 the bishop will
capture in one move recapture in one
move so a6 again a very interesting
treatment of the position other ideas to
try to play for like h6 and b6 and stuff
like that and very normal but here of
course the idea is very similar to some
ideas from the Queens gambit accepted or
some of the Slavs he wants to be able to
take on c4 and then to play the move b5
and Bishop e7 and develop that
problem-child
this Bishop of ciick is always a
problematic piece in the Queens gambit
except a queen gambit declined so again
there are several possibilities a3 was
played in the game c5 normally c5 is a
move that we really roll our eyes at but
once the pawn has moved from a6 it's not
such an outrageous move normally of
course b6 is played and then immediately
if b4 than a5 just excellent position
for black now that the pawn has already
moved after b6 I can just take it and
again I'm first on the C file so this
move is not without some value of course
but I can just play a move like c6
so something like this just and you know
B 4 a 5 something like this can happen
very normal
ok so in our game a3 was played once
again white is not moving his Bishop
from f1 because he's expecting upon
capture on c4 so eight six again a very
standard move kind of asking the bishop
where he wants to go first of all it's
an escape sir for the King in a very
very very long run but also in many
lines if this Knight wants to move with
the idea of reducing the the pressure of
the pin when the bishop is here
sometimes you can just slide the f4 and
just not trade for the bishop on e7
saying my bishop is better than this
bishop when eight six bishop h4 is
played especially when this night ends
up going to e4 or h5 then Bishop g3 is
not so easy to make as the knight will
capture it and black is assured that
trade of Bishops will happen so you know
even h6 makes a lot of sense Bishop h4
and he took good choice he understands
that you know he cannot play any useful
moves himself he kind of ran out of
moves that he wants to make what he
really wants to do is to develop his
Bishop on c8 so he says okay I'm not
gonna wait for you to develop your
bishop so let's do it and b5 now
Capablanca had to make a decision on
which diagonal he wishes to keep the
bishop he played Bishop e2 but I'm
thinking that another interesting we
were able to play Bishop a to
maintaining him on the a to g8 diagonal
which increases his control over the d5
square definitely a Somali you see that
in this game kappa blanka of course is
trying to play for a win as we called
because he has million or a million ways
to make a draw but he's trying to be
ambitious of course in there maybe at
the end of the game when he shook hands
and resign maybe he regretted them so
Bishop e2 Bishop to b7
yeah I should make a note here that two
moves are on the agenda
Bishop b7 and c5 both are very
principled the question is what movie
would what move order to choose there
were as it happened in the game it
didn't make any difference because why
didn't try to to stop the move c5 but
the point is that when black plays
Bishop e7 as we will see it gives why he
added choice of playing the move b2 b4
trying to never allow C far from being
played well we'll see what what what
what what I mean he could play c5
immediately as well wouldn't make any
any difference so but Bishop e7 is
basically inviting before and you'll see
that after B for a5 of course the
principle reply and again there are many
many crazy lines if Knight takes b5 then
c6 and when the knight withdraws we just
wind upon on before that cannot be good
for white rook b1 is possible trying to
defend the pawn but then again black is
going to play Knight d5 and release
himself from the pin so the question is
sure you stopped c5 but whatever you
gain I mean you gave yourself a very
weak pawn on before maybe this is not
very advisable so and Queen b3 again
take on b4 black is doing ok the long
story short he decided to just ignore it
and he canceled and the game goes down
that path c5 and pawn takes e5 again I
have to tell you this position that
again kind of resembles positions from
the Queens gambit accepted actually
where you take on c4 and eventually the
Bishop regains the pawn you can play a 6
and b5 it's very much similar to that
although most of the time the bishop is
not pretty on h4 in that position so
takes takes and in this position he
played 90 for the commentary was saying
that maybe in this position he should
have just resigned himself to the fact
that he doesn't have much and played to
get equality meaning trade Queens takes
takes and rook fd1 I think that if this
would have happened like I like to say
in my lectures we would never see this
game because they would probably agree
to a draw within I don't know X number
of moves
they'll be it's very hard to believe
that anybody can lose this position
white or black
so but of course right now karma Blanca
is completely unconcerned dand he just
wants to play and the movie played is
not a bad one by the way Bishop d4
that's fine
I mean 94 okay so rook c8 again very
logical the game continues at the game
itself you sylheti it plays and
continues in on very very sensible
ground right now okay
each had their declaration of the center
the center got dissolved all minor
pieces are out for both sides of both
sides canceled almost like a classical
treatment of the position so time to
bring the rook into the game there's an
open file let's fight for it
and now I play the move b4 now
intuitively when I saw this move I saw
it without commentary I didn't see any
notes and immediately something struck
me as this move just makes no sense to
me because yeah you kick the night from
c5 but you relinquish the see Foursquare
forever and you make the C file a little
softer from your point of view because
the knight on c3 doesn't have its
natural be to support so I'm very very
surprised at this okay the comment that
I said at Bishop f3 and then Queen e2
with the idea of Luke f d1 is a very
solid plan so after Bishop f3 black can
play the move Queen b6 very sensible
developing the Queen and clearing d8 for
his rook
so Queenie to rook f d8 rook F D 1 again
probably the game would have gone into a
path that would lead us to believe to
oblivion because we would never see it
it will just not be exciting enough to
show but Capablanca decides to try for
b4 very interesting 97 again black is
saying I'm not interested in going to e4
where there's going to be some mass
exchanges let me try to keep my pieces
I'm thinking to myself if I want to do
something on the c-4 square which piece
is gonna serve best there most likely
it'll be a knight if I can get it there
without much consequences so I want to
grow 97 Knight b6 and night c4 this is
my plan so he preserves the knight like
so okay again in this position
we can see that the movie is given a
question mark if you can see it on the
board but this is the commentators
question mark when you put this position
in one of the one of the modern
computers one of the engines for example
I used stockfish seven after a long time
of churning he had absolutely nothing
against this man claiming that this is
not you will see in a second what was
the real mistake that was that's
definitely a consensus there but Bishop
g3 in itself doesn't cause much damage
maybe Bishop f3 would again been more
logical because by playing Bishop f3 you
enabled 94 in some positions especially
if the Queen moves from d8 and then it
just makes a draw
just simple to achieve you just kind of
force your way into an equal position
and this move doesn't but that's not the
third enough to call it a bad move so
Knight b6 is promised the knight is
clearing this the road to go to c4 and
again Knight B 3 cap better reviews
Queen b3 got all around but that's again
so far white hasn't done anything to say
that he is in trouble of course the
problem is that he has nothing to play
for and now we just have to make sure
that he's equalizing but he is still
within the realm of life is good so 95
Bishop f3 rook c4 again you will see
that this move gets an exclamation mark
but not according to the computer I mean
the commentators thought there was a
great new but the computer says yeah
might see for just as good
nothing really no problem with it so
rook c4 and right here is a variation I
forgot about this line for some reason
Bishop e2 takes takes takes takes Queen
d7 and rook c8 is coming very quickly
and of course only block can claim any
happiness in this position white has
just nothing to sell so to speak in
opposition so if you not play Bishop e2
he played 90 for Queen to c8
and again a disagreement between the the
commentators and the computer they
attach this move a mistake as a mistake
well it's fair to say that the computer
doesn't think it's his first choice
don't think it's the best move but you
would not give it a question mark it's
one of the move that he's suggesting
he's saying that that's you know an
optional move
it doesn't really destroy the evaluation
of the position he does agree that I
move like let's say queen bee one oops
sorry it's a lot more prudent because
now here and then my d2 forcing the
issue asking the rook what he's gonna do
takes takes Queen a8 with a more or less
dynamically balanced position again
probably I would prefer to be blocked if
I was asked but because again Bishop g3
and the other bishops are not really not
really doing much but it's not it's not
very likely that one side will win this
game
however after takes Knight takes rook c1
queen a8 and now came the move of course
we can see that the comments are that he
wants to play a move like let's say
Knight c3 or Knight takes b4 because of
the domination in the diagonal so
especially 90s before so he played the
move Knight c3 now this move the
commentators gives absolutely no comment
but that's a question mark that's a
mistake for sure that the computer has
no it's completely consensus among all
the analysis engines that Knight c3 was
the big mistake the commentator make
this move and this is this is what
should have been done Knight c5 you
should have gone for it and after takes
takes rook c8 I'm trying here all the
comments that they give up big if they
say Bishop e2 is equal let me even
Bishop e2 but I I think a4 is the move
that the computer wants to play here
like this and okay they say Knight a5
big advantage for black that's that's
not accurate here there's enough
compensation there's enough enough play
and the weakness of this pawn where
white is generating a lot of play a lot
of counter play and he is again maybe a
little worse but I don't think he should
lose
yeah de pon is gone but I'm gonna go a
four and I'm gonna soften the queenside
and it's gonna be very hard to defend
this pawn because this is not a natural
place for the rock you know the rook
doesn't want to stay here forever I can
always try to chase it by moving my
queen away and playing Knight b3 if I
need you and this again now the two
bishops even if you take this pawn it's
just not enough it's it's an advantage
for black but not not a big one in the
game you'll see what happens and if you
take an imprint of this and here maybe
after a four like I said black has some
some advantage but it's kind of terrible
from White's point of view
you'll see what happens what he did he
did this and moved it gets nothing from
the commentators and I was really amazed
because this really really really gives
um black and a big advantage so rook c8
okay already he has ideas to play the
move Knight d2 and white is gonna be
really hurting his c3 Knight is gonna
need babysitting his bishop on f3 is
gonna need babysitting so he decides to
take I don't know what else to suggest I
think it's reasonable takes takes and
takes and again it's easy to see that
while the knight on c4 is completely
implanted in the white area the knight
on d4 can be II can be easily harassed
name me by Bishop f6 like we see in the
game so he did them of a4 a move that
Hawkins says is decisive from blacks
point of view well it's true that black
already has a big advantage so whatever
white does is gonna have a big advantage
but the computer thinks that a4 is
probably just one of the normal moves
not necessarily worse than h3 that was
recommended by the annotators so a4 and
Bishop f6 very very good he just wants
to take the knight on d4 which will do
two things one completely accentuate the
strength of the knight on c4 compared to
the bishop on g3 which looks a little
bit like shooting in the air it's like a
very beautiful diagonal if we could add
more more squares here something like a
9 and minus a
ten or something it will still shoot up
nothing it does nothing and our light is
very very annoying but again it'll take
some technique to do to do something
about it here he decides to play the
move roof to d1 and Knight f3 excuse me
if rook to d1 oh this is another funny
thing I have to show you
rook t1 and then the annotators go into
this Emilia amazing lecture about how
this is a strong move and after Queen
takes Knight b6 is a strong move okay I
just don't understand why you cannot
play this move and just be up upon and
win the position easily this is just
very very strong in this position so
notice that there's always a mate and
the back rank so I don't know very very
strange
so oops
we had Bishop f6 and we had Knight f3
Bishop to b2 the idea is I want to play
the move e5 and then possibly for
harassing the knight on f3 but I don't
want to do it with my Bishop being
locked I want to first get my Bishop
interactivity and then after a certain
move I will play e5 okay there's a
million variations again of what happens
after rook t1 and again Ruby 193 all
kinds of things but again I want to be
able to show you the second game so I'm
going to speed up just a tiny tiny bit
he played rook e1 not a big difference
for the other variations rook to d8
complete control again the C file that
was White's main achieve blacks main
achievement is now completely blocked
and he just moves away to the D file he
has better minor pieces controls the
file of course we can say that black has
a very very significant advantage pawn
takes pawn takes pawn to h3 again he is
absent of doing something productive he
needs to play moves like this but that's
not a bad move again always making sure
that the king is not gonna be trapped on
the first ring
e 5 very very good block continues with
his plan
after efore in this position then just
queen d3 again very very nice the poem
before I mean you can see that endings
like this after the trade of Queens
again you can see that both a 4 and B 4
are extremely weak pawns while
conversely the pawn on e5 can be
defended further with f6 and I can play
rook b3 take the pawn on b4 live to tell
so he did rook to b1 trying to harass
the bishop pony for attacking the knight
and in this position he had to have
played one of the sad moves either
Knight h2 or 91 but of course on either
one of them there's gonna be a
penetration with the Queen so for
example after 91 Queen d2 it's just very
strong look at the space advantage
better pawn structure better minor
pieces better rook I mean in the long
run it looks hard to defend in the game
he was in real time trouble it's moved
31 and kappa blanka was in real time
trouble
he played 94 and this move should just
lose a pawn but the way he played it he
just lost the game immediately but that
was probably did himself a favor because
nobody thought someone like a European
would not win a position like this
so after Bishop takes of course after
pawn takes Queen takes just upper pawn
with the better minor piece he planned
to play this in time trouble and he
thought well I'm gonna regain my piece
and I'm gonna be able to fight back he
is almost right I mean if not for the
next move this would have been a
fantastic resource however he just
played here and resigned he loses
everything
so for example after Queen d5 rook d5
pawn takes check and it's just hopeless
or alternatively after this takes again
if you try to take on d4 rook takes pawn
takes rook takes again the position with
no no hope whatsoever of course total
totally winning
so kind of a masterpiece by Alyokhina I
think very very nice it's not every time
it's not every day that we see kappa
blanka demolish like this especially in
the middle game and toward the late
middle game in the end game pretty
impressive
any questions about the game if you want
to write down what it was it was again
kappa blanka europe in 1927 okay
so we will go on to the next game our
next game is a little more modern this
comes from the 1966 World Championship
between Spassky and petroleum and this
was one of Petrosyan better games I
think again we know that anybody who
followed petrosian's games know that he
was a very strong defenders very strong
defender and one of his big 40s was
exchange sacrifices he was very famous
for sacrificing in stages and this game
is one of them very very nice so without
further ado d4 Knight f6 Knight f3 e6 is
gonna be a torii attack Bishop to g5 d
592 Bishop to e7 e 397 Bishop d3 so far
I'm going relatively fast because this
has been more or less normal c5 c3 b6
castles here and he plays 95 ok of
course the other plan in this position
is to play a4 with the idea of playing
a5 and try to get some activity on the
Queen side but he plays for this now
it's time for black to be a little bit
on the alert if I'm going to get to play
the move f4 or rather Queen f3 Queen h3
and then at the right time started
dancing my F pawn that could be painful
so notice that in this position
Petrosyan does not castle which is in my
opinion very accurate not to castle so
he takes right now force him to take
with the D pawn Knight to d7 and if you
remember the comment that I made on
queen pawn openings before I said that
sometimes when the knight moves and the
bishop is here and not here he doesn't
have to
and you can just go to f4 and preserve
itself well he does it here except that
again every position is very independent
then here Bishop f4 might not be the
best idea
maybe Bishop e7 would have been a little
more to the in the spirit of the
position so Bishop f4 and okay already
both the commentators and the computer
agree on the move that should have been
played except they give it dubious and
the computer says good move
so g5 here h5 that should have been
played that's I I don't know what what
the commentators were thinking but
that's a good line one of the reasons
why the bishop should not come to f4 so
he played Queen c7 and in this position
Knight f3 was played and they mentioned
the move Queen g4 with g5 as a very very
bad idea from white point of view but
probably the best move is a move that
was not even mentioned and that is Queen
h5 that is probably the most challenging
move in the position notice the g6 Queen
h6
you cannot take here cuz Queen g7 and
this move is maintaining the balance of
the game defending ePHI for now and even
if later I have to play Knight f3 at
least my queen is kind of nagging in
enemy territory he chose to play Knight
f3 h6 again I moved that deserves no
introduction he wants to play g5 without
losing the pawn without having to mess
up things before looking for his chances
on the other wing g5 Bishop g3 of course
he's really hoping that he will take on
before allowing giving him the d4 square
for the knight and then maybe Knight d5
but the rook is gonna come to c1 so of
course this is a very nice hope but you
know not gonna happen h5
once again we see that the threat is
very simple just when I play age for
trapping the bishop so you have to play
here and takes very very strong the best
move again you want to open files you'll
see what he did during the game how he
used that open G file and in this
position he went back Bishop to f4 and
again look at the comment above if you
try to regain the pawn by playing here
then first things first I'm gonna close
things up on the queenside by taking a
temper over the bishop when the bishop
moves bishop will take the knight and
you're sent upon his mind of course this
is just great for black I have an extra
pawn I'm attacking the pawn on c3 which
is not so easy to defend and white
really has nothing to show for it at all
no attack no initiative nothing he has a
beautiful default square but what piece
is exactly gonna is gonna put there
exactly he would rather have a knight if
I can have an idea set of this bishop
and put it here I will give you that
porn anytime of the day but that's not
not possible so Bishop f4 was played and
black castles here now Spassky played a
move that really amazed me because when
I'm looking in this position I'm
thinking myself well you have a great
chance right here right now to open up
things by playing B takes e5 you know
something is going to open up do it but
he doesn't do it he goes a4 and in my
opinion that's not a very smart nerve
for better or for worse he should have
taken here and now black has several
choices if you take with a piece you
give me the d4 square for my knight
that's a huge asset that's a tremendous
asset for me that Knight is very strong
and it can still hop to places like b5
and then maybe d6 it's very dangerous if
you take with the pawn then after rook
b1 I definitely have some chances I have
an open B file look at this position
keep an again a mental picture of it and
then compare it to what happened in the
game it's it's uncomfortable to me so
what he did was he played a4 maybe he
thought that black has no good way to
change the structure and he is now
threatening a5
on top of everything else and we'll
always have eight xb6 as a temple
whenever he needs it but look what he
did see for again an anti positional
move completely but he assessed
correctly that it's worthwhile giving
him the d4 square just to close the
Queen's are completely from any possible
attacks because the initiative on the
kingside thanks to that open G file is
going to completely outweigh the knight
on d4 a very intelligent decision but
you will see that it involves an
investment later an investment of
material so okay well Bishop f5 was
mentioned as a possibility but again
hard to take it too seriously Bishop e2
a6 the key move in the combination you
must be able to lock the Sun the Queen
side now if B 585 and if a 5 B 5
so there's no more chance for white to
attack at some point when you will go
here I'll close this way or this way
doesn't really matter whether you push
it or not and you leave it like this or
not it's just of no consequence
everything is closed here but White has
one thing to show for all this that's
the knight on d4 not enough a Trojan
says so first of all King h1 sooner or
later you have to move the King rope the
g8 we can see already that the move
water is just not very important rook to
g1 again maximum defense rook g4 and now
of course if you play Knight h2 or
something like this then Luke g6 if the
knight goes back I'm just going to be
able to double on the G file for free so
Queen d2 if you ask what about Knight to
d4 if the answer is coming it's the move
order again doesn't matter it's going to
happen very soon so row here and a5 b5
but you leave it like this or play b5 or
whatever that's the same on the
queenside roof d1 Bishop f8 9h - well
blacks idea of course is to play the
move Bishop g7 it's a moment and just
put overwhelming pressure against this
pawn so Knight h2
on 94 I think something very similar
would have been played
he simply takes the pawn on e5 doesn't
even bother to move that look from g4
I'm very aesthetic and very correct
passive exchange sacrifice so he takes
the pawn Knight takes pawn takes let's
stop for a moment and take stock of the
situation
black lost a minimal amount of material
what did he get for it i centralized
Knight a very strong mass of pawns
starting all the way from H all the way
to a you notice that black hasn't lost a
pawn he is missing a rockin he's missing
a minor piece that were traded and one
was sacrificed but the pawns are all
intact so E for well this is a bit of a
nervous nervous move by Spassky based on
a tactical trick maybe it would have
been smarter to leave the pawn here but
I think that he already realized that he
is in sitting and waiting mode black
he's gonna play Bishop d6 to unpin is
night after which that night is gonna be
threatening to go to all kinds of places
and again at the right time pawns are
gonna be advancing in every direction of
course once the knight will move once
the bishop is here the knight moves
ephod f5 all those pawns are going to
advance and white has nothing to attack
he's up in exchange but look where his
rooks are routes would really love to
have open files but they don't have them
so he tries this of course it's a little
cheapo if you play pawn takes pawn out
of greed Bishop takes Knight is very
embarrassing because you notice that
there's a make on d8 so well of course
he wasn't impressed continues with his
plan Bishop to d6 very very wise 23 and
if g3 then f3 okay that's just a note 97
a very Petrosyan like very very patient
takes takes and now White had a
once-in-a-lifetime chance to try for
something here he played the move rook
to d4 that's just not gonna cut it
this is totally inviting blah
to play what he played in the game the
best move would have been to play the
move f4 and now we have a dilemma on one
hand we don't want to take because
that's just ruin our key side pawns and
opens up the file on the G file where we
know why there's two routes Black has
one and on the other hand once you play
f5 then e v Queen c7 okay that would
have been probably the hardest for black
to to break black would probably have to
do something like 9 here Knight here and
try to play for d4 it's a moment and I
know h3 and the bishop on the long
diagonal only black has counter play
only black can play here but white is
still stubborn maybe for example we can
put a rock on d4 and just sack it if we
need to instead well what he did was
just not very good
he played rugby for he 5 immediately and
maybe Spassky thought that this is a
good provocation that he advances the
pawns managed but you'll see that that
was a very bad decision to the point
that both the computer and Newman
suggests rook takes d5 here but clearly
this is a bankruptcy of the strategy by
white if you have to take with the rook
here Bishop takes pawn takes and then
something like f5 well who would you
want to be in that position I know that
I would love to be black so of course
passkey is trying to preserve everything
by playing here but now came another
bolt out of the blue
f5 fantastic just extremely strong play
by Petrosyan he's just sending all his
infantry on the white army so well what
did you if you take well let me show the
little variation because it's important
on this comes this and notice that now
you cannot even dream about touching
your Jeep on because d4 check is going
to kill you and I'm about to go d4 and
I'm about to go H take G and d4 and you
can see that the white position just
completely falls apart this position is
just bankrupt so there is this this
Greek gift on f5 is out another
alternative or they mentioned it also
after it takes f5 if Knight f6 is also
very strong
so he took on d5 I mean otherwise I will
just play f4 I'll take on e4 just to
keep taking stuff so he took here
f4 and he played Queen a 4 if Queen a 7
the e4 pawn is gonna keep advancing and
black is gonna have four pawns on the
King side on the fourth rank on his
fifth line so he tries this Knight f6
Queen f5 King b8 again a very
picturesque position it's one of those
positions where yeah you have an extra
exchange you have an extra room so to
speak on the board for a minor piece but
while the rooks have no access no lines
of action the minor pieces are
terrorizing your position so again what
did you after Queen e6 he would just
trade trade and this attacking the rook
in the pot on f2 what a discouraging
position to have is white just
depressing really depressing and
alternatively he played f3 Bishop c8
Queen ER to go all the way back g3 again
you can imagine that this is not really
closing because h3 is coming very very
shortly and there's nothing to do to
stop it
so rook e1 h3 after pawn takes g2 and
Queen here followed by Queen takes h3
and something coming on the edge file
horror horrible so no so he played
Bishop f1 route h8 it's coming winter is
coming so takes takes
in the game he played King G one after
Bishop takes not rook takes because he
wants the Queen in front of the rock and
therefore this and Queen takes h3 with
well we'd made to follow so that's not
fun he moved the King away from the line
of the rock so takes again if roof takes
Queen d7 and the Queen comes to the edge
foul quickly he tries to run with the
king efore and not a beautiful shot
again when you have a lots of pawns you
can give some of them away in order for
to make the other ones count so after
pawn takes f3 with a threat of rook h1
mate he's just stopping the King from
running away
he tries Queen d-19 g4 and not a beauty
he can even sack the night just to make
the pawns roll forward
of course the knight is threatening to
go well where isn't he's threatening to
go H to e3 anywhere from every direction
so he took it f3 white is up a whole
rook but yeah good luck so route g2
trying to give away some material takes
and resigns just simply resigns after
Queen takes or King g1 roll cage one
simply after King take g2 rock h2 and
the Queen comes to the game of course
the black king is in no danger because
the white pieces are too far away the
black queen and rook are going to give
checkmate momentarily I think that this
was really one of the Trojans nicest guy
I've seen a lot of nice gains by him but
this game really really impressed me
he is playing someone like Boris Spassky
he's not playing a class player and he
is playing you like almost like he's
playing someone in the cyma giving him
material with no fear playing very
aggressively with black and you just
feel like where was sparse key in this
game sure he had to make mistakes but he
makes it seemed like he was never in the
game